sendeschluss für donald trump weil er
weiter zu gewalt anstiften könnte hat
twitter den account des us-präsidenten
nun dauerhaft gesperrt
straßensperrungen und strenge kontrollen
der ganz große ansturm auf die deutschen
wintersport gebete ist diesmal aus
gebieten dreifacherfolg der deutschen
bobpilotinnen in winterberg ganz vorne
laura nolte und anschieberin deborah lee
wie sie holen den em titel
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen wer
heute am samstag die sportnachrichten
hat wie den arbeitnehmern dabei ein
stück von mir zu beginn das thema das
vor allem aber nicht nur die usa
umtreibt wie geht es weiter nach dem
sturm aufs kapital welche konsequenzen
soll es für die aufrührer geben
präsident trump eingeschlossen
15 der randalierer sind bereits
angeklagt darunter auch der mann der am
schreibtisch von nancy pelosi posierte
die vorsitzende des repräsentantenhauses
fordert dass sich trump dafür
strafrechtlich verantworten muss twitter
hat jetzt trumps benutzer konto
dauerhaft gesperrt und ihm damit sein
wichtigstes sprachrohr genommen die
plattform begründet das mit dem risiko
weiterer anstiftung zur gewalt
die demokraten fordern den rücktritt des
präsidenten und wollen am montag ein
neues amtsenthebungsverfahren auf den
weg bringen
aus washington benjamin daniel es ist
amerikas bild des tages nach mehr als
57.000 post wird der wohl meist
diskutierte social media account der
welt dauerhaft gesperrt
die begründung von twitter aufgrund der
letzten tweets auf dem account und den
aktuellen umständen sehe man das große
risiko weiterer anstiftung zur gewalt
diese hatte am mittwoch für solche
bilder gesorgt auf einem jetzt
aufgetauchten video ist zu sehen wie
brutal der mob gegen polizisten im
capitol von joe biden verurteilt die
twitter propaganda seines vorgängers
scharf das erinnert an goebbels und die
große lüge mann wiederholt sie immer
wieder und verankert sie in den köpfen
das hat trump übrigens selbst
angekündigt damals er sagte wenn ich
meine botschaft nur oft genug
wiederholen glaubt ihr die sperrung des
accounts kommt laut kritikern viel zu
spät
jahrelang seien twitter und co profiteur
und katalysator der radikalen
botschaften gewesen
trump postete seine entrüstung
schließlich auf anderen accounts auf die
er zugriff hat darin heißt es twitter
habe sich mit den demokraten
abgesprochen und wolle ihn und 75
millionen großartige patrioten zum
schweigen bringen
wie so oft lieferte er keine belege für
seine aussagen und so wurden auch diese
post mittlerweile gelöscht dennoch us
präsident kündigte an über die gründung
einer eigenen social media plattform
nachzudenken
währenddessen arbeiten demokraten weiter
intensiv daran ein neues
amtsenthebungsverfahren in gang zu
bringen
sollte es dazu kommen und erfolg haben
könnte trump in zukunft nicht mehr für
ein öffentliches bundesamt kandidieren
ein freiwilliger rücktritt den auch
viele fordern ist nicht zu erwarten
freiwillig wird er wohl tatsächlich
nicht gehen aber ines trams in
washington
wie viel sinn hätte denn ein engagement
verfahren überhaupt noch so kurz vor
ende seiner amtszeit am montag bereits
wollen die demokraten im
abgeordnetenhaus ein
amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen trump
einleiten wegen anstiftung zum aufruhr
wie wir hören sind auch einige
republikaner offen für ein sogenanntes
impeachment die demokraten wollen
zweierlei damit erreichen zum einen
wollen sie die große symbolische geste
eines weiteren amtsenthebungsverfahrens
gegen schon zum anderen wollen sie
verhindern mit diesem impeachment dass
trump jemals wieder ein öffentliches amt
ein öffentliches bundesamt besetzen
dafür dass könnte mit einer
zusatzklausel erreicht werden könnte
dann nicht nochmals fürs weiße haus
kandidieren
der zeitplan ist eng demnach könnten die
demokraten im abgeordnetenhaus
erschaffen bis zur amtsübergabe mit
einem verkürzten verfahren kamp
anzuklagen juristisch umstritten ist ob
danach das verfahren weiterlaufen könnte
denn es ist ja immerhin auch noch eine
zweidrittelmehrheit im senat notwendig
und gewiss auch ob dann tatsächlich so
viele republikaner dabei mitmachen
würden sie müssten sich dann entscheiden
haben sie weiterhin angst vor trump und
seiner wähler basis oder wollen sie sich
und ihre partei endgültig von trump
befreien
über die chancen eines neuen
amtsenthebungsverfahrens eines transfers
washington vielen dank vier jahre donald
trump der scheidende präsident
hinterlässt ein gespaltenes land
hintergründe dazu finden sie in der zdf-
heute- app in einem interview mit einem
amerikanischen politikwissenschaftlers
zum stand der korona pandemie in
deutschland das robert koch institut
geht davon aus dass wegen der feiertage
die daten frühestens kommende woche
wieder belastbar sein werden
das lka registrierte knapp 24.000 700
neue infektionen binnen 24 stunden
zudem wurden 1083 neue todesfälle in
verbindung mit 19 gemeldet geimpft
wurden bis heute mehr als eine halbe
million menschen bundesweit
gesundheitsminister sparen sieht
deutschland damit auf einem guten weg
was das impfen angeht und findet es
klappt zug um zug immer besser ähnlich
sagt dass bundeskanzlerin merkel der
impfstart sei ein langsamer start
gewesen
doch das tempo werde zunehmen bis die
impfungen für alle spürbar erleichterung
bringen dürfte es allerdings noch dauern
volker wutschik angesteckt im altenheim
dem thüringischen weimar sind in wenigen
tagen mehr als 20 bewohner in den folgen
der korona infektion gestorben
fakt ist dass deutschlandweit die
impfbereitschaft des personals in vielen
altenheim unterschiedlich ausgeprägt ist
bei den pflegekräften in der altenpflege
in der stationären altenpflege bekomme
ich sehr unterschiedliches
zurückgemeldet
teilweise nur 20 prozent der belegschaft
teilweise 80 prozent der belegschaft
aber leider häufiger die geringere zahl
und weil das so ist trommelte
gesundheitsminister heute via internet
für eine höhere impfbereitschaft
angesprochen ärzte und apotheker sie
sollen bei ihren patienten und kunden
für das impfen werben zurzeit sind
nämlich nur 55 prozent der deutschen für
die korona impfung bei vielen sind noch
viele fragen offen etwa die kann ich mir
das mittel bei montech oder moderner
selbst aussuchen
antwort nein darf man nicht weitere
frage darf man bei den beiden
vorgeschriebenen impfung zwei
unterschiedliche präparate einsetzen
auch hier ein klares nein
ja also das darf im augenblick auf
keinen fall gemacht werden
einfach deshalb weil es dazu überhaupt
keine daten weltweit gibt also wirklich
null daten gibt
das tal ist noch nicht durchschritten da
sind sich immer mehr politiker einig
sachsen hat den schatten schon bis zum
17 februar verlängert andere länder sind
offenbar kurz davor mit maßnahmen wie
der 15 kilometer regel in hotspots will
die politik auch einen neuen ansturm auf
ausflugsziele verhindern
am vergangenen wochenende waren viele in
die verschneiten mittelgebirge gefahren
allen appellen zum trotz mindestabstand
war da oft nicht einzuhalten
deshalb kontrolliert die polizei dieses
wochenende bundesweit weil wieder viele
in die natur ziehen
sven glas berichtet um 9 uhr 30 heute
morgen ist schluss niemand darf mir rauf
auf die schwarzwaldhochstraße weil in
den höhen schon jetzt alle parkplätze
voll sind ausnahmen gibt es auch nicht
für menschen aus der region
oben sind zwar einige unterwegs
langläufer wanderer rodler
doch weil früh abgesperrt wurde ist man
heute weit entfernt von chaotischen
zuständen wie am vergangenen wochenende
es kam es so viel besucher aufgrund der
schneelage dass die gerade die
bundesstraße hier entlang höhe gebiet
beidseitig zugeparkt wurde und
rettungsdienst überhaupt niemand
durchkommen verkehrschaos auf der straße
viele besucher von weither auf
parkplätzen und pisten wurden
abstandsregeln oft nicht eingehalten
bilder die es auch andernorts in
deutschland gab in villingen in hessen
wurden die ski pisten und rodelhänge
regelrecht überrannt die dürfen jetzt
nicht mehr betreten werden
im weiten umkreis des großen feldbergs
in hessen sind nun zufahrtsstraßen
gesperrt
es ist etwas ruhiger als am letzten
wochenende das hat doch wohl einige
verstanden dass das mit den autos in den
taunus nicht mehr so läuft und so gibt
es an diesem samstag vielerorts auch in
hessen deutlich weniger besucher in den
schnee gebieten
wir haben die gesperrte straße genutzt
sind hier hoch gelaufen um dann hier auf
der gesperrten straße ganz alleine nur
wir zwei mit dem hund rodeln zu können
und so hat es zwar auch heute wieder
viele menschen bundesweit nach draußen
gezogen
doch die maßnahmen der behörden in den
schnee gebieten scheinen gegriffen zu
haben während das virus in deutschland
präsenter denn je ist erlebte china
monaten relativer ruhe
doch die ist vorbei grund ist ein
ausbruch in der provinz hebei binnen
weniger tage wurden dort mehr als 300
fälle nachgewiesen
zwei millionen metropolen sind
inzwischen komplett abgeriegelt die
behörden sind alarmiert denn das
neujahrsfest steht an und mit ihm eine
reisewelle stephanie schöneborn
sie nennen es das zweite war die elf
millionen stadt chengdu
heute schliessen u-bahnhöfe keine
öffentlichen verkehrsmittel dürfen
erfahren
in den städten direkt vor den toren
pekings wurde das kriegsrecht verhängt
in den sozialen medien berichten leute
aus vororten über den lockdown der fast
über nacht kam die letzten tage durften
wir nicht zur arbeit gehen
ihr dürft nicht raus mussten drei tage
warten um den zweiten corona test zu
machen
die kinder durch nicht zur schule gehen
jetzt müssen wir warten bis wir weitere
tests machen und wie die schulen dann
entscheiden wissen wir nicht
china hat angst die maßnahmen sind
radikal schnell mit dem einen ziel 0
infektionen straßen werden desinfiziert
insgesamt 18 millionen menschen im
lockdown weil es mehr als 20 neue
infektionen am tag gab tausende
medizinische helfer führten innerhalb
von drei tagen massentest durch in
speziellen labor zelten werden die tests
ausgewertet
heute verkündet das chinesische
staatsfernsehen die zahlen würden wieder
sinken
die brisante der neue ausbruch auch
politisch ist zeigt dass der
bürgermeister von chittagong bereits
entlassen wurde
es geht hier auch um einen
gesichtsverlust der sieges ruschin pings
über das corona virus war sehr laut die
druck ist hoch 50 millionen menschen
sollen bis zum chinesischen neujahrsfest
mitte februar geimpft werden
normalerweise beginnt dann die große
reisewelle dieses jahr fordert die
regierung auf nicht zu reisen
kurz vor dem machtwechsel im weißen haus
stehen die zeichen wieder auf
konfrontation zwischen nordkorea und dem
westen die usa seien der größte feind
seines landes erklärte nordkoreas
machthaber kim jong un um das eigene
überleben zu sichern werde die young
sein atomwaffenprogramm weiter ausbauen
neue raketen würden getestet pläne für
ein atom u boot seien bereits
abgeschlossen
in indonesien wird ein passagierflugzeug
mit 62 menschen an bord vermisst die
behörden befürchten dass die maschine
ins meer gestürzt ist vor der insel java
wurden trümmerteile entdeckt schon kurz
nach dem start war der kontakt zur
boeing 737 500 abgerissen
ihr ziel war pontiac auf der insel
borneo
offenbar verlor die maschine in weniger
als einer minute knapp 3000 meter höhe
die ursache ist noch unklar wer führt
die cdu im jahr der bundestagswahl
wenige tage vor der wahl des neuen
parteichefs lieferten sich die
kandidaten laschet röttgen und märz
einen letzten gemeinsamen schlagabtausch
auch csu-chef söder meldete sich zu wort
mit einem deutlichen lob für laschet
dort ferber über den schlussspurt der
kandidaten
jeder auftritt ist in diesen tagen
wichtig für armin laschet ist es heute
der digitalen neujahrsempfang der cdu
nordrhein-westfalen das kandidatenrennen
der christdemokraten auch hier natürlich
thema wir sind ja alle drei aus
nordrhein westfalen und ich glaube wir
haben auch der partei gezeigt wie man
auch in so einem wettbewerb fair
miteinander umgehen kann egal wie das
ausgeht wir stehen am ende alle zusammen
und helfen neben der gewonnen hat heute
gibt es erst mal lob für lasches
regierungsarbeit von gastredner markus
söder dem selbst ambitionen aufs
kanzleramt nachgesagt werden gestern
abend haben die drei kandidaten für den
cdu vorsitz laschet märz und röttgen zum
letzten mal vor dem parteitag nächste
woche debattiert es ging um umwelt
sicherheit und außenpolitik
inhaltlich gibt es kaum unterschiede in
stil und ansprache ich bin kein lager
ich stehe für alle und ich glaube auch
dass diejenigen die mich nicht wählen
werden wenn ich gewählt werde mit mir
leben können und mich akzeptieren
ich bringe mit regierungserfahrung
leitung eines großen landes ausgleich
zwischen unterschiedlichen interessen
jetzt geht es darum nach vorne zu
schauen
einen aufbruch zu wagen erneuerung zu
ermöglichen in deutschland und in der
europäischen union und einer der gar
nicht am tisch sitzt mischt auch noch
mit jens spahn eigentlich im team
laschet soll mit parteifreunden seine
chancen aufs kanzleramt ausgelotet haben
sparen lässt das dementieren wie
plastikmüll exporte aus deutschland sind
2020 gegenüber dem vorjahr deutlich
gesunken um zehn prozent so die
schätzung des bundesverbandes der
deutschen entsorgungs wasser und
rohstoffwirtschaft demnach wurden im
vergangenen jahr knapp 900 90.000 tonnen
kunststoffabfall ins ausland
transportiert das entspricht einem
sechstel des hierzulande anfallenden
plastikmülls größter abnehmer ist
malaysia gefolgt von den niederlanden
und der türkei
in spanien sorgt sturmtief philomena für
chaos mindestens drei menschen kamen
bereits ums leben
philomena brachte rekord kälte und so
viel schnee wie seit jahrzehnten nicht
mehr
mehr als einen halben meter hoch liegt
der schnee in der hauptstadt madrid
viele straßen sind nicht befahrbar und
auch die meisten züge stehen still
der flughafen hat den betrieb
eingestellt und nun zum sport und
servieren arbeit und zur
fußball-bundesliga unter hat schalke 04
nach sage und schreibe 30 sieglosen
bundesliga spielen in serie endlich
wieder gewonnen und das ganz souverän
gegen hoffenheim
die bisherigen ergebnisse des 15
spieltag schalke schlägt hoffenheim 4 0
leverkusen und bremen trennen sich
unentschieden 1 1 freiburg besiegt köln
klar mit 15 0
union berlin gegen wolfsburg
unentschieden 2 2 und mainz unterliegt
frankfurt mit 0 2 das abendspiel leipzig
gegen dortmund bereits gestern besiegte
gladbach die bayern mit 3 zu 2
die tabelle münchen könnte die
tabellenführung heute abend an leipzig
verlieren sollte er gegen den bvb
gewinnen
dritter leverkusen fährt er jetzt union
berlin danach dortmund wolfsburg und
gladbach die zweite tabellenhälfte
beginnt mit augsburg ja und am
tabellenende
bielefeld sechzehnter und schalke hat
die rote laterne an mainz abgegeben und
das topspiel leipzig gegen dortmund aus
für dich bei uns im aktuellen
sportstudio um 23 uhr und jetzt im
wintersport em doppelerfolg für die
deutschen rodler im lettischen sigulda
gold für felix loch silber für johannes
ludwig und em dreifach erfolg für die
deutschen bobfahrerinnen allen voran
lauter laura nolte die mit ihrer
anschieberin deborah lee wie im interweb
siegt laura nolte die derzeit
erfolgreichste bobpilotin der welt
grundlage ihrer erfolge die überragenden
start mit anschieberin deborah lee wie
zweimal statt bestzeit und darauf
aufbauend auch zweimal lauf bestzeit
europameisterschaftstitel mit 42
hundertstel vorsprung
die deutschen rivalen cali p straft rang
drei teilen sich die deutschen team
gefährtinnen janka viebig mit den
österreicherinnen bayern unter sagna
gleichzeitig neu dritter sieg im fünften
weltcuprennen und auch die deutschen
männer sind bei der em in winterberg
doppelt im 2 erfolgreich francesco
friedrich wird zusammen mit seinem
anschieber torsten marx europameister
mit einem satten vorsprung von 67
hundertstel vor seinen landsleuten
johannes lochner und eric franke für
friedrich war das gleichzeitig auch der
45 weltcup-sieg zweierbob rekord
eingestellt und schon wieder gewonnen
kamil stoch der sieger der
vierschanzentournee landet auch beim
weltcup-skispringen titisee neustadt auf
rang eins bester deutscher markus
eisenbichler der wird vierter da ist es
wieder das gute gefühl dass markus
eisenbichler zuletzt vermisst hat starke
139 einhalb meter im zweiten durchgang
rang vier auf der hochfirstschanze in
schwarz sagt es ist nicht optimal und
kommt trotzdem ins fliegen und das ist
angenehm
momentan haben wir glücklich sein
zufrieden sein seine gratulation gilt
kamil stoch der tournee-sieger mit einem
traumflug auf 144 meter
er gewinnt das springen geprägt von
schwierigen wind vor dem weltcup
führenden norweger kran rüth und biotit
schiefer ebenfalls polen
doch morgen wieder skispringen live im
zdf und das ganze wintersport heute
morgen und dann schon ab 10.15 danken
aber kalt und schön ist das wochenende
denn auch morgen scheint häufig die
sonne nur über den norden ziehen
dichtere wolken mehr gleich von katja
horneffer das war es von uns danke für
ihr interesse
marietta slomka und das heute journal
heute gegen 10 vor 11
wir wünschen noch einen gemütlichen
abend und sehen uns hoffentlich morgen
wieder punkt 19 uhr tschüss
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren die
hochs und tiefs westlich von uns haben
alle gleich zwei zentren interessant ist
zum beispiel das tief bartosz das
allerdings in spanien philomena heißt
das sieht nämlich jetzt nach osten
weiter und bringt den schnee dann nicht
mehr so doll in spanien sondern in
italien für uns in mitteleuropa
interessant werden antje 2 und 10 x 2
schon morgen in der nacht ist es meist
klar an der donau bildet sich nebel
das kann auch noch glatt auf den straßen
in sachsen fällt auch noch ein bisschen
schnee die temperaturen sinken in
norddeutschland auf 0 bis minus 4 grad
in thüringen bayern und baden
württemberg geht es dagegen auf minus 5
bis minus 15 grad runter und nach dieser
doch sehr eisigen nacht bleibt es am
morgen auch am alpenrand besonders kalt
da steigen die temperaturen kaum auf
minus fünf grad die meiste zeit des
tages ist es also noch kälter am
mildesten wird es morgen an der nordsee
mit plus 4 grad und von der nordsee
kommen dann morgen auch dichtere wolken
heran
die bringen dann am nachmittag ein
bisschen regen es könnte auch mal eine
schneeflocke dabei sein sonst wird das
ein sehr freundlicher sonntag sonne und
wolken wechseln sich ab wenn nicht
gerade mal nebel und hochnebel stöhr am
montag ändert sich an diesem wetter noch
nicht so viel aber am dienstag dreht der
wind auf nord west dann kommen schnee
schneeregen und regen und es wird sehr
gefährlich glatt auf den straßen
schönes wochenende